the House of the Seven Gables is a is a
clear-eyed and realistic tale of an
economy in transition a new england
world of inherited privilege funded by
sea journeys where there are no more sea
journeys to fund this this way of life
and an age of commerce and of hustle is
beginning we're introduced to Hepzibah
Hepzibah pension an old woman who has
for years and years lived off the
diminishing funds of a family
inheritance and Hepzibah belongs to a
particular stage in American history and
to an American elite that's really at
its utter in its last gasp we're
introduced to Hepzibah on the morning
that she has to do what no lady had ever
had to do in her family that is she has
to work for a living Hepzibah has
decided that she must open a cent shop a
little 7-eleven on the side of her house
or starve and so she's bought some few
provisions some threads some gingerbread
I think of halves of a little bit like
the the senior citizen who has to go to
work in a McDonald's or those grumpy
client unfriendly cashiers who at
Christmastime one finds in department
stores they're hired for the Christmas
rush they were not suited to this
business but there they are and Hepzibah
when she hears the little bell in the
the little bell ringing for her services
her she quivers and quavers through her
whole frame she's so nervous that
standing behind the counter she knocks
over various of the sundries she's
collected for customers and and
hawthorne gives us this comic pathetic
view of her in her rusty gown with her
bony old buttocks in the air as she
scrabbles on the ground for the marbles
and and spools of thread she's lost and
so what one can get from hawthorne as
from from no other american writer is
what it feels like to have hit bottom
helping us to sympathize with a person
who has hit rock bottom whose life
suddenly and irrevocably has been
changed Hepzibah who's had to open a
cent shop it turns out doesn't have any
of the skills she needs has no certainly
has no sense of client services doesn't
really even understand the marketing the
marketing demands of her of her moment
hawthorne is hard-headed enough not to
pretend that old woman Hepzibah is
actually going to be able to remake
herself is going to be able to enter
this new commercial economy in which she
lives but lucky for her her cousin
arrives and her cousin has marvelous
ideas about how if they just brew up
some ginger beer and she herself Phoebe
can roller sleeves up on our snowy white
arms and can concoct that ginger beer
that they will be able to make this sent
shop a going concern and what the House
of the Seven Gables tells us is that an
older generations ways will will recede
into the past and that with luck a newer
generations initiative and energy will
will not only
deliver society to the next stage but
also provide a bit of a safety net for
that prior generation so I do think that
Hawthorne is describing succession
natural succession and insisting that at
moments of change we actually have to
look to the next generation certainly in
the current economic crisis we're
looking at older persons who had no idea
that the preparations they'd made for
their lives the way they saw themselves
had no idea that those preparations and
and that self understanding would be
inadequate Hawthorn's clear-eyed
unsentimental and yet deeply sympathetic
and compassionate view of what it is to
be older what it is to be older and
unequipped for the present day i think
is invaluable and a text that since it's
available for free the one can read it
on one smartphone I think that we should
all be reading the House of the Seven
Gables
you